Modeling the effect of wind seems to be pretty straightforward.
It looks as though we simply have to push the fire through the forest with a certain velocity.
If the left curve is the temperature distribution at times 0 after 1 time step, h will be shifted
to the right curve, and the amount of shift amounts to the time step times the velocity.
As we are storing these values in an array, the wind will simply shift their position in the array.
The tricky thing, however, is that the time step times the velocity is really small.
We would have to shift these entries by a fraction of a step. How would you do that.
Here comes a different approach.
I want to get the new value, the value on the right curve at the position X₀.
I get that new value by looking it up on the original curve step size times velocity to the left from here,
and now the trick is to use the derivative of this function.
Let's write down what this new value is.
The new value after 1 step time equals the time step h.
At this position, x₀ is approximately the old value T(0, x₀) and now we have to take care
of the difference between these two, and if we estimate it using the derivative,
so all our correction the length of that green line will be step size times velocity this length
times the derivative--this slope of our tangent.
The derivative is the partial derivative of temperature with respect to x
at times 0 and position x₀, and we have to be a bit careful about the sine.
If the derivative is negative such as in this case, we have to go up,
which means we need a minus sign in front.
So that's the trick, we use the spatial derivative to accomplish this shift.
As usual, however, as with all these methods, we have to be careful about not taking too large steps.
This value with step size in time times the velocity has to be reasonably small.
In particular, it should be pretty much smaller than our grit size Δx.
The way to compute this derivative is, of course, to use a central-difference formula.